once again i want to welcome us all and
um
we have heard so far about the progress
of what
uh the of what the omixlogic african is
actually doing in nigeria i
in a beat i will be calling on
on
on a few persons i hope we are tasty
enough to
to look out for
for these persons that um
that
will be joining us very very soon yeah
my name is
tutu i am a molecular biologist and
geneticist
and i'm a phd candidate i ill from
nigeria
i
i
got my
my higher education in pensa russia and
i'm a faculty with russell academy in
russia
i'm a blood pathogen uh certified expat
and and i am also an enthusiast of
of data analytics data science
uh population genetics bioinformatics
regenerative medicine
i harm the african the omixlogic africa
community engagement manager so uh it's
so lovely to be here on this note i
would love to
to uh be prayer to prepare us uh please
i would love that um
professor
now as i read his profile
so uh we will be having a
talk session now where uh professor will
be bringing us uh
some some insight into bioinformatics
research in africa and the impact that
it has on the world
um professor charles i literally is
presently a faculty member
at the microbiology department
he is the the acting dean
of the faculty of science at all state
universities in nigeria
he
we are very utilized application of
biological techniques and
microbiological processes for the
actualization of sustainable
developmental goals and
agrarian revolution through quality
teaching research and community
development he's currently the acting
director of intellectual properties and
technology transfer
he is the age dean of
faculty of science and
and department of microbiology in iowa
state university he's a visiting
professor and an as an an executive
director at the center of biotechnology
pressures canadian university in
embardon nigeria
he has won several scientific awards and
grants for renowned academic bodies like
council of
council of scientific and industrial
research in in india department of bio
technology in india
the world academy of science in italy
netherlands
fellowship program
and so on
uh he has won
grants from from the agency of
international development and
cooperation in israel uh royal academy
of engineering in the uk among other
places is published
many scientific journals and articles
and
conference proceedings in referred
national and international
journals with over 370
manuscripts he is around about amongst
the top 500 prolific authors in nigeria
between 2019 today
by scorpios and cyber
his research interests include
microbiology about technology both
obvious management and nano technology
he has recently been appointed as a
president
and the chairman the governing council
of the nigerian bioinformatics and
genomics network society
is presently
a syria editor with taylor's and charles
usa editing several textbook on
on agricultural
biotechnology nanotechnology farmer
foods and
environmental sciences cena is an
editorial board member of many
international journals and serve as a
review of many
double-blind peer review
journals like el silva springer francis
and taylor willy blues one nature
american
chemistry society bedroom science
publisher is a member
of many scientific and professional
bodies including the american society of
microbiology about technological society
of nigeria nigerian societal
microbiology it's presently
the general executive secretary of the
nigerian young academic
he has won a lot of international
recognition i has also acted as the
keynote speaker delivering
invited talk position p-pass
university research institutions and
several centers of excellence which we
span across several continents of the
globe yes over
over the last 15 years build a strong
working collaboration with reputation
reputable research groups in numerous
and leading
society
at this point i would love to call on
professor charles
to give horse
to take over so professor charles are
you there can you hear me
yeah professor charles can you hear me
oh we can't hear you mr charles are you
there
everyone
yeah good evening we can hear you now uh
you mean can you see my screen
uh you may need to switch your screen to
to the display i mean yes yes we can we
can we can
yeah can you hear me can you see me
yeah
we can
hear you uh we can see you
uh okay
but continue sir
okay good afternoon everyone can you see
my screen
yes we can
here we can see your screen hello
yes yes it is visible okay
good good good afternoon everyone i'm so
grateful doctor i am fair uh i love you
too for bringing me to this great
conference
i found it as a great privilege
uh to be talking to you
uh today i'll be talking about some
recent bioinformatics innovation
at queen's surname for of
numerous global challenges
and today
as we know around the world
a lot of people are going through a lot
of challenges a lot of problems
so it is not high time we come together
as a scientist
in order to solve the global problem
now
kobe knife thing was not ever sage in
some years to come
and bioinformatics
has really played a lot of key role now
we are in posts covet error
which shows within the level of things
so this is i serve as the product of the
job information genomics network i'm a
distinguished professor of biotechnology
bioinformatics
and also i'm the executive secretary of
nigeria young academy and summer
community of west african microbiology
of nigeria
so
before we go on this one from this
opportunity we are talking about where
does he come up he step up from the word
of god
uh which shows
everything
a compassion about god
so we from the gtct of everything no
matter whatever we want to discover want
to grow about everything's all about god
so what i will say in essence
my information become a sustainable to
airports
to achieve the digital revolution
about the sustainable language we have
been talking about about subsidiary city
sustainable food water
health being
a well-being of mankind and energy
decomposition
and talking about education gender and a
lot of other stuff so we show secularity
on a lot of things and a lot of place to
play now the old world is going through
a lot of
low-carbon economy and a lot of other
things so mindfulness are becoming
sustainable too that happens to have a
kind of economical
eco-friendly to manage a lot of things
talking about metabolomics and a lot of
other problems
this about shows that
bioinformatics have become
a kind of encentric cycle
that encompass around innovation
sustainable environment and circular
economy now we are trying to digress
from linear economy now the whole world
is talking about secular economy
now which shows that bioinformatics have
a lot of plague rules to play around the
problem
mostly during the era of post coverage
now
talking
about about industrial four are allowed
friends to play
with the help of bioinformatics we're
talking about nine pillars of
technological advancement now we are
talking about the level of technological
advancements and developments of
bioinformatics have played a lot of
crucial they're talking about industrial
stream you know solar city does a copy
and industrial intelligence have come to
play today
that's what we are talking about
now i would like to share some of my
experience as a distinguished professor
of bioinformatics baltimore and by
economic bodies
now before i go on
there's a particular model that has
really helped me in achieving some of
this societal omega
most of my uh feel revelation of how to
emphasize
divine ivs potential time and tests
before biochemists can become adaptable
everywhere
we first of all need all to go back to
our local community identify the major
challenges we have to emphasize divine
identity and test the program now
now that many of us have not done a lot
of things
but we are mocking into what is called
translation research
so there is difference between research
translation and transition research now
before we are talking about millennium
development goal but now all of us are
talking about
our society legal we form a kind of
for commissioning on the rights of
ethiopia so
bioinformatics as a two have become a
crucial tool for us to have this diverse
set of development goals now it has been
stipulated that the whole group is going
to increase that security to 9 billion
in the year 2050.
as we know
fao estimated that there is generate
almost 60
transformation and
in terms of agriculture for us to meet
the band of the ever inclusive
population now the issue of climate
change is there so we shows
uh
definitely bioinformatics have a lot of
role to play now there are four major
goals of our time
how do we achieve food security issue of
climate changes earth and high rate of
environment now
my research will have been able to
discover
a new herbicide to the head of
bioinformatics which we have established
the molecular basis
and we have done a lot of sequencing and
there's showing the uh phylogenetic tree
which shows the uh relationship between
various strengths of the verb beside us
that could be used to uh form a kind of
permanent replacement to chemical
synthetic uh arbitrage and this is
showing the publication uh publication
another complication that shows uh the
stability and the active compound and
through the use of some biomultiple uh
techniques in order to establish the
most active ingredient present and
probably one for that to show the mode
of action that all the published paper
and documents additionally uh term and
the biochemical activity that joined
together with some biomatic results
which i will see explain further we went
for that to see the
metabolomic aspect and carried out the
structural illustration using the uh
hplc fdr as well as an nmr and uh cozy
45
95 105 causes it to show an
unestablished relationship between the
genomics bank of artists
ovens and the protonates of the perhaps
agent not only that do we stop at the
research level we went for that to
document our patents in this regard and
we have done it now don't eat coffee we
do a lot of
works that have to do with artificial
intelligence edge and a lot of
internet of thing-based smart
agriculture because
uh we discovered that
bioinformatics have come to be a
sustainable tool that we could use so
what do we do we recite into the use of
agroblocks
a comic kind of robot most israeli in
all accessible area now we have
challenges of some infrastructure
especially in nigeria some of my
students i'm really working on it we
went for that i was talking about
climate change earlier so one for that
to see how comedic conditioning could be
manifold and automated system could come
to place not only is that we're going to
step on estrogen conversion production
of social services
and we want foreigner to show and
establish internet of things in
monitoring aquatic environments and a
lot of other stuff then one further to
see how we could design the kind of
intelligence system that will enhance
its such water stream production using
our boozy logic not only that done in
2021 when there was calvary
uh my research team uh that is being
edited by dr wade zaming from india we
went for that to show evolutionary
protein structure analysis of various
cadaver mosaics because uh cassava form
a kind of staple food that has been
consumed and used by many people in a
lot of industry and uh
carbohydrates but the yield loss
ranges around 1.9 to 2.9 billion per
hour in eastern the center was of africa
now
proficient virus we're researching so
because they have a kind of
multifunctional graphic rocks around the
virus and all seeds are very recycled so
what do we do there is a lot of
information on whether the scm uh
chromosome virus satellites have a kind
of relationship that relates around the
protein calls and co we got a kind of
newborn pesticide that could be used to
manage so what do we do i employ uh our
research group use a lot of
bioinformatics uh techniques to achieve
this and this has been established and
this is showing a lot of
cool called families around it and
showing the philosophy around the
provincial infrared level joining method
using mega software we went for that to
show the graphical alignments of the
copy my theme and went for that to show
the distribution of the console muscle
region uh
in the causal mosaic vira not only
enough we will be able to
establish the three-dimensional homology
mode of the cosmos virus and we were
able to compare the biology to process
ontology it's a lot of product
components ontology and molecular
function ontology and the graphical
representation of the active gene so the
radius we discovered that
are the profane codes to be used and
serve as a kind of new bioprocess
that could reduce a regulation of
management of carcinomas like virus so
this is showing the gene reports uh
where we publish the africa also our
group headed by dr rosanni
uh also
projects overall activity
on activity and we did a lot of our
robust programming of the surgical b450
in agriculture american industrializable
understand uh more insight into their
personal origin family especially on
professional fashion now whatever uh
this week will also receive a very big
award but was sponsored
and given to or the little girl dr
rosalie
uh
uh he got it grabbed by american society
of microbiology
and federation of european microbiology
society
and many delegates that give us a travel
hour to america to present this
paragraph so what might say in essence
we were able to establish the tasmanic
distribution of the putative in our
various aspergillus range and this
showing the original trends were able to
establish the prediction of the
subcellular localized analysis of the
protein uh gene in this reverse fabulous
and this is showing some of the
secondary metabolism uh cluster for the
various phenols that we tested after we
went further to establish the white
genome of our sexual authentic species
and this is showing the evolutionary
relationship within the
p450 gene in taxinotonia species and
this is just some solar cytochrome
profit in various fashions in the
secondary marble life in the 13th house
and uh this is showing the publication
with recently grabbed our group
that's where we have established the
role of interest by javascript and we
went further to establish the
evolutional relationship between them
and this is showing the various uh game
also
in austin area we have been able to do
that and uh
also we've been able to establish
comparative uh of the
from fusion species also this is under
consideration because to cerium
and some other
uh sponge species
like uh
spg loss parasitic cause because a lot
of
problems of aflatozine so i was good
i've been able to establish through the
airport by marty's uh tools to establish
uh some antarctic strengths that could
be used and establish a kind of a
jointly bio uh competitive uh
with toxogenic string that's these they
could use to eradicate oxygenated
strains aspect of it that is responding
for formation of cancer and relevance so
my group also work on crystal regularly
enterprise shock patterning spread
called crispr and we have used it and
recently we won a grant from usa eu
african-american caribbean institute and
not to see with the help of nanotube and
genetic engineering as well i think how
we can easily pass
genetic material into the energy showing
the graph and we have done a lot of work
in uh application bioinformatics uh to
establish active compounds for
microorganisms and this shows some of
the result of the blast we've been able
to get and establish and uh presently we
now discovered on some vegetable until
beneficial of our microorganisms like
endothelial established are very safe
compared within that and recovery use
and towards the progression of a drug
that could be used for management of
several diseases now also we also use
some biomatics and natural resources to
see
in silicon screening of selection
medicinal plants who serve as a both
implication for kobit uh whenever they
understand so in this particular story
over 132 phytochemicals from uh xenia
binaries understand
was screened as a potential transparency
membrane three and we were able to
establish using insulator method to
establish and destroying the sequence
alignment of the profile sequences and
this is showing the appropriate
recommendables for the variation of the
modern disruptive profile and we went
for that to show the result of the
morning sets of politicians may use in
our program and we also show the three
of the catholic church supporting marvin
and uh a lot of interaction with the
university of uh
finance collaborating ahanam and this
chain for the money aloe vera and this
shiny publication uh
where we have documented our findings so
crispr we've used crispr also in our
group for a lot of things uh for
monitoring or with my apprentices and we
have from a lot of work on our machine
learning and efficiency and deep
learning the management of everything
and also we've established a lot of work
and we are functionalist and really in
healthcare um
virtual momentum mixed reality and we
went further to about america and
transforming uh high alternative
athenian robotics
has been used by some other group not my
group and management of sql services in
gene therapy
and uh
in other genealogy and they use it in
management of
liver disease and also for sabotage of
organs
impacts and the reducing malaria
are then using reproductive medicine and
crispr baby also he's going on a great
region a lot of what have been done in
that and hiv management cancer
management in fixing a lot of
hematological disease however uh crispr
being used for generalization and future
practitioners
and a lot of applications for adoption a
lot of scientists have done a lot of
work and application of bioinformatics
in position of vaccine and love work is
she also growing in nigeria also uh
during this reviews uh a lot of
diagnosis techniques for marijuana baby
machine learning from
uh
hemorrhoids
offense of internals of airplanes the
carbon monoxide mines smart same thing
now my research with some of my pd
students are working in the development
of bar sensor that could science and we
use a lot of
the alpha by random muscles are in
position of this uh
uh about sensor and we use a a lot of
that technique for diagnosis also in
treatment of copyrighting now on the
whole for me to round up
it has come to a point that we
in
kind of multidisciplinary approach
nature integrates whatever we are doing
and and compassion as a universe success
making bioinformatics as the moderator
so that means we have to allow
transitionary interest very important
sorry about the scenario needs to come
together we need to work together for us
to form and solve the majority of the
global problem
now i will say that we need teamwork we
need to carry the students at secondary
school another one i remember some of
the time the cv and governor came to my
university now to see whatever we do so
we need to carry government along we
need to involve people so at this point
i would like to invite many of you to
join my series at us i'm a service
editor to server test box so you can
join me and you can see some of the
projects uh that this reads by promoting
another about technological advances
that we have done you can join them and
this is my company or away command i
would like to invite all of you to
recent advertising about technology one
behind the program with it and this
changed some of the programming we have
in the past and uh
definitely i see by informatica why am i
showing this we need awareness we need
to synthesize people we need to conduct
training it's some of the training where
we invite expertise in the other
minorities that they visit nigeria and
we can still collaborate for more of
this not only that we need to talk to
the government i was invited by the
senators of the federal republic in 2016
and last week to come and talk about
science so we need to talk to the
government about what we are doing so in
view of this let me say thank you
for all the opportunity
uh
these are some of the professors that
have really helped me and some countries
and also
looking forward to collaborate with you
and talk for more opportunity
thank you so much professor uh you've
actually touched a lot of these things
and you were able to go to 175
slides within that period of time uh
thank you so much we've seen how that
professor has touched on different
aspects of research even from the
microbiology perspective to integrating
genomics and doing quality research
thank you so much professor it has
actually really been a great time uh
being been here
with you uh it's actually been a very
very great time
being here with you um on this note i
would love to see that
uh our next presenter
uh
she is on ground and uh
and it's so lovely to really have our
year i'm going to share my screen now so
that
we will be able to see the next person
um can we see my screen
yes we can
so can we see my screen can you hear me
too
yes yes
okay
so real quick i would just love to to
introduce uh dr venueraz uh she just had
a simple
uh introduction because of the time
uh she is a training and outreach
coordinator with hereditary held and uh
what's the third age you're gonna get to
know
bowel network south africa so uh
uh dr vinomiraz are you there yes i'm
here
okay please uh can we give her the the
uh co-ops right so that she can share
our screen
she's already
all right uh please just go into into
the full screen mode so that we can see
your screen maximally
can you just confirm that you are seeing
my screen and autopsy interview
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we can see you
now
great okay perfect so hi everyone
yeah you can see your
presenter view yeah
okay so let me just see if i can switch
it is kind of in the presenter mode we
can still make use of this yeah perfect
now
sure okay sure you can see it now
yeah
perfect so hi everyone i am very nervous
i
package so i just want to thank
everybody for firstly inviting me um to
be with you all today
it's it's
been a really wonderful day so far
actually i've really been enjoying all
the presentations all the talks and from
and learning from everybody else's
experience as well so i'm getting a
warning that my internet is a little bit
unstable so if you all don't mind i'm
actually going to just switch off my
videos so that my screen stays up and
you can hear my audio
but i'll switch it on a little bit later
if my internet stabilizes a little bit
right so just to give you an overview of
what i will be just touching on briefly
with this talk i would like to give you
all a brief overview of hca buying it
and who we are
i'd like to cover very briefly as well
some of the hda bionic training
and also our training models
i will discuss our multiple delivery
training model in a little bit more
depth than some of the other things i'll
talk about because this is a model that
we really really are really proud of um
as as an organization and a lot of
development went into this model and and
i'll talk to why it's been such an
amazing model for us and then i'll also
talk to how we've adapted this model
more recently for much more advanced um
bioinformatics training and then i'll
touch on some of the other mechanisms
that we are using um to share our
training and make it a little bit more
reusable a little bit more findable um
and interoperable so i'll speak to faye
and bio schemers a little bit and then
i'll speak to the dsi africa initiative
but more specifically
el wazi which is the open data science
platform and the
um group that i'll be forming part of
going forward
so for those of you who might not be um
too familiar with us i just thought i'd
do a quick introduction to ho by net so
h3a bionic is a pan-african
bioinformatics network and we are part
of the human hereditary and health in
africa consortium also known as h3
africa
and at the moment we are currently
comprised of 28 partners and we are
spread across 17 different countries and
so we have quite a nice representation
across africa already which i'm quite
happy about and i'm sure everybody's
quite proud of
and we have over 200 members at the
moment so we are quite a large
consortium at the moment
but h.a bionet was established to
develop bioinformatics capacity in
africa and more specifically to enable
genomics data analysis by
africa researchers across the continent
and that was our our initial goal and
aim that it's expanded a lot more since
then
um but mainly basically h.a bionet is
developing human capacity through
training and support for data analysis
and also facilitating access to
informatics infrastructure by developing
or providing access to pipelines and
tools for predominantly human microbiome
and pathogen genomic data analysis
and so the major goal of course of hr
buying it overall is then to increase
the number of qualified bioinformatics
graduates on the continent but also to
create research opportunities and also
very importantly provide some financial
support for promising new graduates in
the area of bioinformatics
one thing h.a bionic really wanted to do
was to
kind of slow the brain drain in africa
and attract some africans back to the
continent um who are studying abroad so
to make africa more attractive as a
bioinformatics you know
leader across the world
and so one of the ways that we of course
do that is through training and that's
um predominantly what i do as part of
h.a binet i work with training work
package and we work on um you know
designing inclusive training models um
and
just unique training modalities so that
we can reach as many people across
africa as possible
and so h.a buying it does training in a
number of different ways um so we have
run over the course of the last decade
or so a lot of face-to-face workshops
we've done a lot of train the train at
style courses so we focused on
developing capacity in trainers
we've also
awarded quite a few internships
um and so internships have obviously
slowed down a little bit during the
cover years now but
before that we did try to
move graduates around so they could get
hands
experience in different labs and that's
also been something that we try to push
quite a lot
we've done a lot of live and online
training
and we also focus a lot on hackathons
and jamborees and each of these
components are done with a different end
goal in mind
and i want to say that when hga bionic
just started
obviously the focus was a lot on
face-to-face workshops
and so
with that we ran many face-to-face
workshops but we realized very very
quickly we've got a huge network across
africa and when we run face-to-face
workshops we are reaching 20 to 30
people per course or per workshop and so
that was really just not good enough and
so we wanted to create models that could
reach more and more people across africa
simultaneously so that we could actually
train more people simultaneously and in
that way also increase capacity for a
lot of this type of work
and so one thing we really um worked
very hard on is developing this sort of
multiple delivery mode training model
and so it uses a lot of different
approaches um to to teach particular
courses the first course that we ran in
one of our flagship courses is our
introduction to bioinformatics course
um and this course was run because of
course there was a need for just
foundational training across africa when
h.a buying it just started up a lot of
people wanted foundational training but
we couldn't run you know 100
face-to-face workshops in a year and so
what we did was we decided well let's
try this multiple delivery mode training
model and it was designed to reach
multiple classrooms multiple sites
across africa at the same time and how
the model works is that we would
basically have institutions apply to
host the classroom so we'd have a call
for classrooms um they went through a
regular selection process and if we if
we felt that they had the
the capacity to run the workshop they
were accepted as a host we then allowed
a round of participant applications and
each classroom basically had this set of
participant applications they did their
selections as well and these
participants then joined that classroom
but what made this you this model really
really unique is that although it was a
distributed classroom model within each
classroom we had a coordinator we had a
teaching assistant and we had a systems
admin for on-site support and then we
had all of us in the background as the
core team
also supporting those classrooms with an
added level of support and so what this
allowed us to do is to reach hundreds of
participants across numerous classrooms
every year now we're running ibt
actually now for the seventh time this
year and last year we had something like
50 classrooms running at the same time
spread across about 15 or 16 countries
in africa
and we had close to 2 000 people taking
the course at the same time and that was
really fantastic for us
um so the whole course we feel is quite
scalable we started with about 26
classrooms and it grew organically to
about 50 classrooms i don't know if we
can have more than that this year
because my capacity is waiting a little
bit thin to manage everybody um but yeah
for all intents and purposes as long as
you have more hands on the core team the
model can continue to grow on end really
but what we did with this particular
model is we made use of a lot of online
tools initially because we wanted to
remove that infrastructural burden on
the classrooms because they were spread
across africa they all had different
issues at the time sometimes they they
were low resourced in terms of capacity
some classrooms had intimate internet
and so we all are aware of a lot of the
problems in africa it's a very very
heterogeneous sort of environment and so
this kind of made the environment a lot
more homogeneous because now um
everybody was using the same online
tools and so all you really needed was a
computer and a browser and you were good
to go
but then we started training thousands
of people across africa and so now
everybody was coming back to us and
saying well this model is wonderful
but how can we do something more
advanced or can we do something more
advanced
and so
at some point myself and uh and another
training person at h.a beyond it went
well let's try and do something more
advanced and let's see how it goes and
that kind of spurred and
sort of led to the development
of an adapted multiple delivery model
and so what we did with um 16 escorts
that we ran for a couple of years now
is we actually had
a bunch of people from different domains
come together so we had us as the
trainers and the curriculum developers
we had developers come together
sys admins come together and we decided
well let's try and package all the tools
the data sets software dependencies
packages everything into a container
let's actually now try and get these
classrooms to pull that container
install it manage it run it locally and
then see how they feel
and so what we did with this particular
model is we had a smaller cohort of
classrooms because now the
infrastructure became very important h.a
pioneer has invested a lot in
infrastructural development across all
of our nodes across africa and so we
were quite confident that the
computational resources were there um in
most cases and so we also wanted to have
them develop their their own ability
both for 16 years analyses but also for
planning these kinds of courses and
workshops on their own even if they
share buying it disappears for whatever
reason
so what we had them do was pull these
containers give all these students
access to their servers or clusters
wherever the container was hosted and
they actually needed to run analyses in
the cloud for the course
and so this
a lot of people kind of told us um
you're a little bit crazy we don't
really think this is going to work
but i'm really proud to say that it has
worked and it's been working for a few
years now
um and we've run i think about three or
four iterations of the 16 years course
now and at the last course we had about
30 classrooms who all ran this course in
this sort of model and it worked really
really well
one thing we also do with the model is
we actively manage everybody with a
learning management site and so we
actually track every single participant
all the time and so we give them graded
tests and assignments
there's lots of feedback tools forums
and we manage literally every single
participant quite actively and we also
grade everything that they do and so
this was a very exciting model for us to
see work
but also then caught the interest of the
international community really and
last year for the first time we teamed
up with the welcome trust and they've
got a wonderful ngs course that they run
but their course is run obviously with
with slightly different model so they
use a vm
and so we tried this model last year for
the first time um for that njs course
the vm was incredibly large it was about
40 gigs unpacked when it was up it was
20 gigs and so each participant had to
pull this vm and then you know work with
us via the learning management site and
online lessons um because of covert they
couldn't join their physical classrooms
anymore so the whole course became
virtual um but it still worked it became
a truly blended learning experience but
it was really exciting for us to see
that whereas the welcome trust could
reach 20 people per workshop and they
ran the workshop maybe twice a year
last year alone i think we reached i
think over 300 people with with that um
training and it ran for about three
months this year we have about 600
people on the course and 59 classrooms
doing ngs analysis and really advanced
analyses um so they're doing everything
from qc to rdc gypsy genome assembly
really the whole shebang they they're
going they're working their way through
the content and they're managing and so
that's also been really exciting for us
and so i won't speak to to a lot of
these these topics um in too much detail
um just in the interest of time but i
did want to just touch on a couple of
other things that h.a buying it has been
doing
um to just increase and grow the impact
across africa as well
and so one thing we are focusing on
quite heavily not just in training but
overall is the concept of fear so making
everything findable accessible
interoperable and reusable and so we are
making sure that we are really hitting
all of those fair indicators whether it
be with our software in tools or with
our training materials
and one of the ways that we are making
things more fair is also by implementing
bio schemas and so we are currently
testing the implementation of
bioschemers um so bioskimmers allow you
to mark up your website with some
semantic text and so it allows obviously
scrapers web scrapers especially to find
your content quite easily at least in
the case of training materials and so
there are three different schemas that
relate to training and so we're trying
to implement them and what this will
help other web scrapers and people who
host catalogs of training for example to
do
is to automatically pull in any training
we've ever done
once these schemas are implemented and
again in that way we are making our
training materials
very much more findable and accessible
and it's also being duplicated in a lot
of other repos which which i think is
very exciting
we also have embarked and assisted with
a lot of competency development for
bioinformatics
so the international society for
computational biology has suggested a
core set of
competencies that they would like
bioinformaticians to have
and so what we do is we actually use
those competencies to drive all of our
curriculum development even workshops
and courses are mapped to competencies
because it's very vital to us that we
actually develop these competencies at
an appropriate level for the for the
audience or the user the end user
so what the the iacb competencies have
done in the past um
is that they've come up with a whole
bunch of personas i've just taken a
snapshot of a couple of the personas
there are very many more than these
um and then what they've done is taken
the competencies they suggested core
competencies
and they've used bloom's taxonomy to map
out you know at what level does all of
these different personas need a
particular competency and so what that
does is really just help drive the
development of your course and make sure
that you're heating the the competency
at the correct level for that particular
persona and so i've just got a couple up
here on this screen you can
get a physician a lab technician a
physicist and a bike curator for example
and then i've just pulled out um just a
snapshot of some of the competencies
these are not all of the competencies
they are more than these um but these
are just the first few so you can see
here that um
basically we map we use bloom's taxonomy
to map the level or the depth of
knowledge that they would need or
ability or competency for these
competencies um so just for example
statistical research methods um we would
basically suggest suggest that all of
them basically have knowledge to
comprehension level in terms of bloom's
taxonomy but a buyer curator might not
have to um
yeah so a bike creator would have to
have this competency at this level
whereas the others could have it at a
lower level but we use it in that way to
just kind of develop curricula and it's
been very interesting the way that our
curriculums have actually changed as a
result
and so
these competencies are actually being
further developed now there's a paper
coming out i think in maybe about a
month's time maybe less
um where we basically are expanding
these competencies to include more data
science competencies but also adding
knowledge skills and attitudes and so we
hope that that will also assist
everybody in using the competencies and
there are there's a lot of other
developments happening around those
competencies um so lots of tools that
the icb for example are working on
automate the tools where you can code to
the website for example and say um i am
a physician
and i want to learn x and they will talk
out what competencies you actually need
to develop to be considered
you know competent at a particular level
so that's been quite interesting for us
one other thing that the hr binary is
focusing on quite a lot are guides and
sops um so if you visit our website
possibly after this talk um you will see
that
we have
a lot of sops
a lot of how-to guides that we've been
developing that's based on a lot of our
work i'm not going to talk to obviously
all the others but i'll talk to the
training guide
we've developed quite a comprehensive
training guide as well so if you do not
have experience in running
bioinformatics courses we've put
together
just a very short guide it's not very
comprehensive but a quick guide to guide
you through the main steps that we
typically take when we design our
training and these steps are on the
slide so you can see that we think quite
thoroughly about the way that we do
training these are our steps just for
workshops um courses sometimes can can
be a little bit more complex and of
course degree programs a lot more
complex than this
but um this is our our basic training
workflow and so we follow this for each
and every course that we design and what
we've done is we've packaged that into a
little
just a simple pdf document that also has
a whole bunch of templates and little um
help guides that can help you do
training in the way that we do it if
you're interested in in that of course
but we've made lots of resources
available everything's been created
under creative commons licenses and so
you're welcome to take it adapt it reuse
it as you see fit and so that's also
something that we're really excited
about and all of these resources are
loaded onto public repositories excuse
me
the one that we use quite a lot is ziva
hub
so ziva hub is the uct instance
of fixture so it's a local instance of
fiction
and so we use this quite a lot um to
upload our materials
um and to make it more findable it
attaches a doi it versions the materials
and so it's really quite lovely in that
way
and we actually upload all of our
training materials now um on to xero hub
and so if you went to ziva hub now and
you search for h a binary you'd actually
see all our all the course materials
that we've managed to curate so far
available as archives that contain
um workflows slides often videos data
sets so just whatever you would need to
actually be able to do that training
hopefully on your own so that's been
quite great
now in the interest of time i'm not
going to speak to the dsi africa
initiative in too much depth but i just
thought i would tell you a little bit
about the
the dsi africa initiative it's quite sad
for me to say that h.a buying it is
actually soon coming to an end we are
ending our funding cycle um we've been
funded for
i think more than 10 years now so um
it's time for something new i guess
and so we've been funded by this new
inner hdsi africa initiative and
basically um
the whole idea behind this initiative is
that infrastructure and capacity
development
are big focus of course of boosting
health research on the continent
and so um the work will be facilitated
through five-year grants that have been
awarded by the nih
by the the common fund which is called
harnessing data science for health
discovery and innovation in africa
and they've awarded actually in the
region of 75 million dollars
um to various research hubs that are
that are in various places and are
focusing on different things um so some
research hubs are obviously data
intensive um so focusing on the science
but then also training groups that are
focusing on increasing just capacity for
for analyses
and um there are also things like lc
research groups so groups exploring the
ethical legal and social implications
and then there's the open data science
platform and coordination center which
is um the group that i'll form a part of
going forward
and really this group just wants to
facilitate the development of a
trans-african network of data scientists
so just to tell you just briefly about
the odsp
the odsp will in essence develop a
flexible scalable open data science
platform for the dsi africa consortium
to find and access data select tools and
workflows run analyses
but very importantly on a choice of
computing environments all through easy
to use workspaces
and then administration and support of
the core resources and consortium will
be con
kind of coordinated by a coordinating
center
and so um
those of us at the central hca pioneer
team we a lot of us will be forming part
of their coordinating center going
forward but together please can you just
round up quickly so that we're going to
have the next uh panel i think we just
have 10 more minutes for the african
section please continue
sure i thought 30 minutes but no problem
um all right okay sure so let me just
actually wrap up then so this is just a
quick snapshot of what that platform is
going to look like we'll have all these
workspaces where you can basically
choose um how you want to run what you
want to run
and it's going to be federated so you
can either bring the data to the tools
or the tools to the data and so we're
very excited about this whole initiative
and where it might lead african science
and that'll stop me